Okay.
Hi folks. We're back live. Quick stream.
45 minutes before dinner.
I just wanted to uh get a couple more
experiments up and running. Do a little
bit more analysis. I have a couple quick
ideas to test out as well.
Okay.
The first thing
not sweeping time steps.
Sweeping frame skip. We can sweep them
M.
We sweeping policy
Weird.
Try this again.
Yes.
What size?
No, nothing.
That is good.
All right. So, we got our policy sweep
set up.
So we'll see if this does anything.
Leave that alone. Now the next thing is
uh can we do
like sweeps
I'm going to try a couple silly things
here. So 1 E5
This is like 200, 800, 2.4 mil,
9 mil. Oh, this is not amazing, right?
I mean, I guess it can run out of
budget,
but that's not great. Yeah, that's
really not great at all.
is there like a reasonable standard
spacing scheme that's between linear and
exponential? Control.
This is actually it. It's just not fine
enough. Right.
What if I do four E5? Is this better?
Oh, that's actually way better. That's
way better resolution, right?
that's way better.
All right, let's try this.
We're going to try to do this real
quick.
So, it's just going to be a bunch of
different sweeps.
Okay, this is that
and then the only difference
is we have break point here.
Go.
I'm just I'm going to try like we're
going to try to oneshot it
wrong with this. Oh, it's here.
Okay.
worker args. I think it's just total
time steps, right?
No, it's
args of train
I do this on box two by box one by
mistake.
I guess it doesn't matter, right?
Oh, I see.
You dummy.
Okay. So, if this works, the goal of
this
uh the goal of this is that we should
now have
Oh, this needs to be rerun.
Uh this puffer box
is fine
Looks fine.
Except I need to do
Look at this.Oop.
Very nice.
Your geometric spacing
2 mil.
So, what we're going to do here,
if we don't freaking break this thing,
We'll see if this is stable. This is all
I wanted to do. This should be a uh as
solid as possible sweep approach because
this is just going to run like six
separate sweeps.
It's possible to do way better than
this, but we don't care. The goal is to
get our first actually clean set of
sweeps that are not terrible and broken
for no stupid reason
Let that run a bit. We'll just check on
this. Anything on X?
Hope
M's real quick for the Okay.
All right.
Yeah.
Oh, this thing.
All right, we'll fix that
again.
I mean, really, we just want to have
this thing
just want to have this thing run all our
damn experiments, right?
long. Do it on breakout. Do it on
everything.
Be great.
Back on sweeps just for a little bit. I
am heading to dinner in 15 20 minutes.
Last epoch.
Guess it's got to be at least one epoch,
I
Boom.
This works. We should be good.
That was like a solid solid sixse second
stomach rumbling there.
I'm still trying to figure out uh what
I'm going to go take myself for when I
finish this cut on Sunday.
Uh FBR really
I would be impressed if you manage to
code it in a way where it's not easy to
change that. Like
17.
Very, very nice.
What's your favorite food?
I don't know. I'm thinking after I run
on Sunday, I'm going to take myself for
steak and French toast.
And
then I'm going to take myself to the
diner for dinner.
Get a burger, get a shake, get some
soup.
Bacon, French toast in the same meal.
Exactly.
It's not that big of a change.
Cut meal was steak and eggs after a long
run,
which I was pretty happy with. I just
wanted some damn French toast
the whole time.
right. So, this is this looks to be
running
We have all sorts of different types of
plots we'll be able to make out of this.
But
this is essentially this is running six
different sweeps where each sweep is
trying to maximize score and minimize
time.
Um,
but then they're each running at
different numbers of steps.
In the UK, it does it like in the
Well, I mean, that's because the UK is
like of basically any country in the
world, it's the country that's known for
having terrible food.
Check Discord. Yeah, my bad, Spencer.
Let me let me go. Hold on.
Hey, Spencer, they have good food in
Texas. Here, he'll tell you.
Spencer, if there's anything concrete,
I'm probably going to go in one day next
week before Thursday. Like someday
Monday, Tuesday or Thursday. Uh Monday,
Tuesday or Wednesday.
So if there's something concrete, I can
probably do something like before or
after my other engagements there
cuz like from that text it doesn't seem
like there's anything that makes sense.
that.
In America, we have good food from
everywhere, but we also have our own
good food.
We got barbecue, we got steaks, we got
Thanksgiving dinner, got all sorts of
good stuff.
Beans on toast, my guy. The fish and
chips is arguable. The beans on toast is
a war crime.
Okay. I mean, this should get us a Purto
Frontier.
It would be kind of hard for this not
to. Uh, I'm going to go check this last
other run that I had going. Make sure
this is still alive.
red cheese and dude this is
this is like trauma speaking I suppose
like you're Stockholmed my guy
come here get some freedom in
All right. Okay. This is the weird
thing.
Wait, how'd this happen?
Oh, I know what's happening. Well, we
can fix this.
All right. Fix this sweep. Fix the other
sweeps. have cool experiments running on
this thing.
We'll see how this goes.
Oh, that's actually crazy. Holy [ __ ]
Uh yeah, this is good. We're going to
crush this. Okay.
Well, welcome. Uh well, for my gosh, I
am not speaking straight.
Thank you for the folks for tuning in
here for the uh short evening session.
If you're interested in my work
generally, puffer.ai for all the things,
star the GitHub, it's free. It helps me
out a huge amount. Join Discord if you
want to get involved. We have lots of
helpful people. If you're new to RL or
getting into Pupper and uh if you're
looking for all of my articles,
educational material, research posts,
and the like, it's all on X long and
short form.
I'm going to go get myself some food
and